I want to start with the tweet from
Reuters a couple days ago because Elon
responded to a response to the tweet and
that certain is going to set us up today
so here is a tweet from Reuters Twitter
not safer under Elon Musk says former
head of trust and safety and then as it
works on Twitter random people respond
to things so this is just a random
person that responded to that tweet by
the name of Eva Fox and said Twitter has
shown itself to be not safe for the past
10 years and has lost users trust the
past team of trust and safety is a
disgrace so it doesn't have any right to
judge what is being done now they had a
chance but they sold their souls they
sold their souls to a corporation and
then here's where it got interesting
Elon responded to that and said exactly
the obvious reality as long time users
know is that Twitter has failed in trust
and safety for a very long time and has
interfered and in elections Twitter 2.0
will be far more effective transparent
and even-handed Kurt we kind of all knew
that they weren't that even-handed or
fair or anything like that but uh
interfered in elections I thought that
was crazy conspiracy stuff yeah that's
what I was told I was told the uh that
our elections are perfectly fine unless
they occurred in uh a year other than
2020.
um
you know it it it's kind of remarkable
the uh that we have a major news
organization like Reuters coming out
really against Free Speech because
there's there's no such thing as safety
safety is a nanny State word designed to
uh justify whatever political action
these folks want it it's funny how safe
the the Venn diagram of safety and
leftism is a is a single Circle uh
and I I I like how Elon Musk just kind
of bowls through it see here's the thing
about Elon and I may write about this
next week in town hall he believed all
this stuff about liberalism and so did
you you believed you know you were a
liberal guy you thought oh Free Speech
people get to say what they want but
that's not what a lot of liberal guys
really think a lot of them think well
free speech is great until it stops
being useful and then it's unsafe or
hateful or some other weasel word used
to justify silencing the opposition and
I I love
that we have Elon Musk I I coming out
and and blasting through it like uh you
know the old Kool-Aid guy in the uh
Saturday morning cartoons 40 years ago
Melissa uh putting aside the election
stuff for a second the idea that he's
getting rid of the trust and safety
people uh you know he went there's that
video of him in the closet getting rid
of the stay woke shirts I mean he is
purging what I think most people
watching this would believe are the the
bad aspects of the employees at Twitter
the people that were going out and about
and censoring and all that stuff I I
take it you see this as a positive huh
yeah I mean how many times in the last
few years have we seen friends of ours
commentators public commentators get
their accounts booted for reasons that
are very unclear right we we see that
with uh the trans debate if you debt
name somebody use the wrong pronoun so
you basically Express I mean Megan
Murphy expressed the radical idea that
you know there are just two genders and
she got banned from Twitter and you can
see kind of like the top-down decision
making process why why this is so toxic
to discourse and you know the truth is
there's only been this kind of landmines
when it comes to speech on on one side
and and I'm glad that elon's coming in
he's fixing it